mais comment on fait pour le mettre
dessus c'est lui là non bon ben ok alors
on va prendre un tadjik voilà je
n'aurais pas dû d'ailleurs puisque
quelques révisions commentaires que l'on
récupère plus de vie qu'on utilise quand
ya le mode entre guillemets dernière
chance qui se met en place un pop up
besoin d'examiner sa lie à quoi peut
entrer là dedans c'est le fouet
pour gross dead surtout des bactéries
d'état
aulas
la voulait taille non au oui
le bullet time le tag ou pas
à eau
oh [ __ ]
or dieu pour but est collectée à rio
hu ou là des samatanais un peu avec les
gardes et d'autres lavage base du wec et
cela cache la pêche
m
non non mais non mais non mais voilà en
saas assez intelligente du jeu combiné à
la mienne d'ailleurs
à assas tessier soir non il reste plein
je l'entends que faire comme l'inde où
c'est un espèce de fall automatique ça
c'est vachement bien présent
voilà up jack ada vous voulez rester
hawks où je suis en vacances non à
maastricht
lol
oh oh [ __ ] de sa mère
si je me prends une balle de sa grosse m
e je suppose
casse toi
ah je n'ai pas tué à la
crève mais comme on le bat footineo
c'est pas de la tête mais comment il
suffit pas et puis c'est un truc est un
mot une fête à travers le temps lui
entre casse-toi mondiale
alors lui cher
ou peut-être charge voilà tiens
stop stop ça ah non attends mais vous
tirez dans quoi tu attends à mes [ __ ]
lève-toi coulon nom a fait un rap est un
mets donc quoi [ __ ] ça c'est pas la
tête il a un casque je sais pas c'est
quoi mon gas mais il a jeté le corps
j'ai pas il est en tout cas son casque
il a acheté à auchan je veux voir des 4
on joue à cache cache a été parfait bon
j'ai pas une grenade bien
alors attends beaucoup on peut tirer
[ __ ]
j'ai affiché dans quoi est-ce qu'on peut
sur elle
dans les couilles
la vie tu perds tu prends des balles de
ça dans le sac
dans la voiture
e
voilà un [ __ ] mais pourquoi tu as
l'air sympa fait sa job l'espèce de
bataille sauf qu'ils savent pas se
passer comme prévu quand il va revenir
au bureau va y avoir un truc super bien
tout comme des gosses pas rien à [ __ ]
je veux des balles
j'en ai beaucoup la 3g tout macbook
parfait alors faut que je retourne à au
bureau il ya l'ascenseur aux dragons
on va regarder d'en récupérer une pièce
en or tient à les gens vous allez être
fier de moi là je commence à trouver les
choses qui entoure le décor quoi
simplement continuer là-bas je suis sûr
qu'il ya abondance et l'offreur
je vois pas parce que j'ai deux pièces
en or il faut les 3 pour avoir
complètement l'harmonie
ça fait ça va pas se passer comme prévu
les notaires j'avais peu d'espoir avant
un strip tease l'état mais pire encore
rigaux
quant aux îles et marc
c'est peut-être son patin c'est ça qu'on
recherche c'est agréable
à la fin de la saison
oh
bois tiens ça pète toujours autant
myspace
je dois aller où
super
l'essai dans la merde
et ben voilà on est dans la merde
pas
c'est par là
allez donc mai
roj
kiev je l'espère mais je pense qu'il
sait pas dans ces moments là
fork
oh
à commencer ce style et voilà tu as et r
pourquoi
ap 20 mai au pied d'accord ça on n'a pas
de livre anne comment bah oui quoi
par finisse
recharges g puis vie
d'abord un [ __ ] de les braves serait
totalement irréaliste mais j'aimerais
bien je vais mourir tu vas faire
cocooner à terme 2
là-bas du doliprane
ici on a un c'est obligé je m'appelle 6
chemin
mais qui en a pas eu mort il ya un mec
là tu vois
casse-toi n'était pas bien toi ok
comment vider un chargeur pour avoir un
mec qui ne bouge pas mal comme faits
avance plus vite la geste ray c'est ce
débile ouais bon
qui se soucie
je prends de baltimore
l'art est archi stratégique tu es le
dernier
mais tu auras mais toi
ah tiens à l'appui hockey ici un
antalgique je le sens là
à temps
avant tout
voilà temps
allez tout aussi amer 10 puis traverse
trop vite je peux pas revenir en arrière
c'est juste le fait que dernière ici
c'est pas sa mission
bon ok mais qui se prend des petits
bergers aujourd'hui
soit une boucle
vers l'impression qu'il fait nuit d'un
coup dehors a peut-être qu il s'est
réveillé en mars et 1 go go go go
et ce parti
et y'a rien qui l'achève pour de bon
poil peu goûté à ça c'est au tout début
du jeu qu'on voit ça au tout début il
interroge le matière devient méchant
genre
il me semble jambes
besson a dit hausse
je souligne augros police ne dispose
chaque mois se doit de mettre leurs vies
ne valent 2008 m
sabia
300 chambres ne vous a perfé à castres
non pas encore
j'ai mis
la mer
m
voilà comme d'hab bref voilà genre le
mec il a rien à part un pansement
d'excusés ans l'homme qui prend des
balles qui brûlent qui tombe dit m
je prends des débris sur la gueule qui
respire plus d'oxygène et chineurs sol
s'est brisé le coeur
alors attendre je vous prends le
contrôle sur ce qui me gêne un peu j'y
parvenais pas ma petite crise de la
quarantaine d'années peut-être ce que je
n'ai pas les idées claires ça fait des
années que je me gavais d'alcool dans ta
g et là c'est là qu'il va se
retransformer un petit plus je crois que
là il sera secondé
voilà
allez hop qui se rase des cheveux blonds
elle devient méchant
ouah
bon ben voilà on a fini premiers disques
ecoutez jean j'espère que ces deux
partis déjà vous auront plus on se
retrouve vendredi prochain pour un
nouvel épisode tout le monde bat pis
à bientôt